the wall will go up and Mexico will  start behaving as far as Timerman  I think I have a great and believe me my  temperament is very good very hard all  the woman on the apprentice courtesy  consciously or unconsciously that's the  expected  listen China your mother we're gonna  attack hit 25 percent to have a country  must have a simulation I'm not the first  one to say this this is a country where  I speak English not Spanish he's not a  warrior he's a war hero because he was  captured  I like people that weren't captured okay  you know it doesn't really matter what a  media rights is as long as you have a  young and beautiful piece of  [Music]